foreign
welcome to megabit everyone it's me Pete
with Mary back uh we're gonna play
another Disney game today it's Aladdin
this is my other childhood treat uh
what's the other one yeah we're gonna go
with the Genesis version of the game
it's made by virgin I believe the same
Studio that worked on Lion King
yeah yeah I think so in fact I'm
confident because they implore the same
techniques from horrible bats really bad
say like hitboxes there's a boulder even
though that's not in either of the
movies there's there's another Boulder
Run scene where you run away from the
boulder it's really poorly it's a funny
game uh unlike Lion King the Super
Nintendo and Genesis versions of Aladdin
were made by different Studios Capcom
actually made the one on Super Nintendo
and you know who was a producer on that
game no Shinji mikami the guy behind
Resident Evil
Peter how do you know these things brain
uh but yeah this one by virgin is
arguably the better one I know that
there have been like panels at events
where people argue and debate but you
have a sword in this one you do have a
sword so automatic win right I think I
mean again super biased the second one
for me is is like definitely this is
like one of my childhood memories it's
like one of the games I'm most fond of
it is really difficult but I think it's
I think
I think that's one of my favorite this
is like one of my favorite games of all
time and it's difficult to beat and I
think that kind of makes it more makes
you feel much better about it when you
finally do do it I watch this I watched
Aladdin for the first time in like a
decade last night
movie still holds up I really like it
yeah
a few things to remember you need to
save Princess Jasmine I hope you guys
take a good look at that photo because
she's not in the game at all that's the
only time uh you see her now and you see
her when you win and that's it so
that's actually the same thing with Lion
King you never see Nala you never see
any um female characters except for
the hyena which is one of the lead one
is a lady so if you guys have not seen
the story this is a good synopsis Jafar
is a piece of [__] he's a real jerk he
is a real piece of [__] he's trying to
manipulate the sultan he's trying to
marry Princess Jasmine he's been popping
off trying to kill and yeah
um
can you do the voice right
haven't you from him yet
quiet Iago patience Iago oh that's a
better one
Cave of Oneness
give me the lamp
let's extend him an invitation to the
Palace
the palace he has that like dead look in
his eyes
all right so
here I am here you are you guys remember
me Aladdin your friend Aladdin I don't
remember him having a sword actually he
never really carries no sword he's a
pacifist in the movie yeah but in the
game I mean he's just he's stabbing
dudes left and right so I got only a few
moves I got my
my standard attack here if I look up I
attack left and right uh and then I can
do like a jab right in the belly that's
a Kill Shot he's also got an abundance
of apples which he uses as a projectile
that's right but like the movie starts
because he steals an apple sort of no
Princess Jasmine gives an apple too
Princess Jasmine some young kids and
then but anyway he has to steal an apple
to then give it to the guy who had the
Apple stolen feels all the time
him stealing
um you get so many apples in this game
you max out at 99 oh I got hit right
away
but you need them forever and it's
actually like a reoccurring thing not
only do you need them for a lot of uh
just like the levels but you can't win
any of the boss fights without without
them oh you son of them yeah like I
don't understand why the knife thrower
doesn't like you because you technically
haven't done anything wrong to him like
I probably stole something from him
maybe but like look out for camels they
spit
I love this animation so much it's good
though this game has way better
animations in the Super Nintendo and if
you get cold in the game you can slice
open his belly and spend the night in
his I heard that's true yes
I got hit by a pot doing really bad
um the coals uh will not hurt you as
long as you're running see
stupid ladies they have so many pots
they couldn't give a [__] about their
pots
you think they're so poor but they don't
do anything about it
that idiot
bad lady gosh I think you can
yeah yeah you can kill them you can kill
the ladies I don't know if it's
necessary
you can just avoid them
were there any sequels to Aladdin like
Remember The Lion King movie yeah oh
yeah there's the Return of Jafar
um which I owned on VHS was that good I
liked it but I owned it so I think it
might have been like cognitive
dissonance that I felt like I had to
enjoy it because I spent money on it
okay well what was the plot there though
because Jafar came back so as you know
in the end of the actual movie Jafar
never died he just got put in a lamp so
what happens is somebody rubs his lamp
and he did yeah he gets brought he gets
brought back
so that's the
that's like the synopsis is that
somebody somebody brings him back as a
who is this somebody though just a
random it's like a new character and
they're like an evil character I haven't
seen this movie in years oh okay so they
they resurrect him on purpose yeah they
they resurrect him with the idea of like
taking over the world and Jafar is like
super down with that so they kind of
they kind of they kind of work together
so then who's the hero in the movie
um I believe Aladdin is is now King and
he like or Prince or whatever and
Emperor whatever they end up being and
he he comes back
okay all right I I can't remember too
much about it but I know that's what
happens
um so there is a sequel in fact I think
there's a third but I don't think I've
ever seen the third one I've only seen
the second one it's probably like The
Lion King where like maybe there was a
limited theatrical release for one of
the sequels but then the other one was
just straight to video get out of here
get
Tim he um cuts my apples with his sword
I think that's a really cool animation
it is yeah
I'm just gonna throw apples at you
stupid
do you remember this song Peter
so this is not the beginning song
There's a beginning song where he talks
about stealing from people yeah yeah um
and then there's another song where he
talks about uh this is like when he's an
actual Prince so it's kind of weird that
they well he's already found the lamp at
this point in the movie he's already
found them that's right well during this
song during the song right yeah which is
really weird because yeah the scene he
hasn't even has he met Princess Jasmine
yet at this scene no yeah this is like
his stealing so this is um yeah he's
yeah he takes the bread loaf and people
are upset so they're chasing him that's
right yeah
um this is like a completely different
scene but I think it's an enjoyable song
nonetheless I don't mind oh
I'm getting killed I gotta I'm gonna go
for it all right
I got killed I did hit a lamp so there's
checkpoints uh when you do a checkpoint
you lose all your apples so you might
actually want to get your apples back
because now you only have 14 apples
I like your approach your approach is to
just run into them
hey Mary yeah
cool
just saying your approach is very
different
all right
take away here they come in girls bring
the bone oh you're gonna love this guy
Prince Ali fabulous he Alia
strong as ten regular and then that's
all I can remember hmm
so hop on drop and drop by do I have to
go back down
ton is he only a Barbara
that physique how can I speak weak at
the knees
we'll get out on that square adjust your
Veil and prepare to gawk and grovel it
man is it Prince Ali oh this is a
purchase shop what do you buy in let's
buy some stuff so if you buy the left
one that's a life the right is a save
but you don't have enough Mooney do you
remember that beginning sequence where
he's selling stuff yeah he's trying to
sell like a something that like makes
french fries if you back up you can
throw apples at them
I took him too long to attack me
all right you're done that's the end of
that level okay
all right so this is there's a few
things coming up now these are like
bonus levels if you hit Jafar you lose
immediately
um you get so you lost it immediately
and then there's the Abu bonus level
this is the only time you get to play as
a boo it's really cool so you can't be
hit by anything so what you do is as
soon as you see an apple that's where
you want to be and you avoid all pots at
all costs so as soon as I think the
first apples on the left same is it the
same every time watch out that was not
an apple mirror go to the right go to
the weight all the way to the right go
all the way to the left now go go
I should have done it
you told me to go to the left and there
were no apples to the left there were
pots change it oh my God
such hubris
we only have an hour
left yeah bonus apples
so this sequence is never in the movie
it doesn't exist
you can't get him with apples for some
reason snakes are known to be immune to
Apples I
snakes Nature's quitters
all they can do is
wear hats
these animations are so weird he
basically eats cakes and if you hit him
with an apple he drops his pants
he's such an embarrassing character
um all right go back and fall to the
right
where's my actual like Health meter so
it's the lamp with the smoke gotcha um
so the less smoke you have the more in
danger you are you probably have three
hits left it's kind of a guess go to the
left
uh what's up stop sign
Aladdin
those weren't even invented yet as far
as I'm aware dinosaur pawns dinosaur
bones never existed
so you jump in the trees you'll get
stuck in them and you'll kind of Squish
through so you gotta constantly jump to
get past this part
kind of hang
the AI for the bad guys is pretty good
like they pretty much attack you
if you're in the camera shot if they're
in the camera shot they're going to
attack you even if they can't hit you
just kind of funny
um if you look to the right that Scarab
thing that increases your points your
bonus points it's interesting that this
game has points because it doesn't
really affect anything else but
I suppose if you wanted to beat it with
a high score you could
there's Iago
Iago is kind of a pain in the wiener in
this game
I'd thrown up with that dude
they've got a lot of reach yeah the
hitboxes in this game are wildly small
and die all the time
I think click we were discussing this
before I do think that Aladdin is a
harder game than the Lion King I think
it just kind of requires more because
when I was a kid I could get decently
far in Lion King but I couldn't get
like far at all in this game like I
really struggled
my uh my issue with Lion King is that
some things seems so Random
at least everything here is kind of like
laid out for you
it's gonna take a break there we go
because animation's so cute and it's so
like the game
I thought I had timed it oh well
um I don't know where you ended up I
might do a Save State just
just so we have it
stop sign
get away from me
um so what is your favorite part in the
movie Peter that's a good question I
mean like the part where Aladdin is
obviously like inside the you know the
what the Tomb of the lamps I mean what
would you even call it just the
underground place you need to go to get
the lamp basically before the genie
appears oh right that's that's a really
good scene uh
I also just like the just that the
setting with Jafar or yeah Jafar playing
the old man like in the prison yeah he's
really good he's a really evil dude yeah
like it's Disney is always so great like
everyone thinks oh these like child
friendly movies like you know but there
are always these really dark moments but
they know how to like temper it just
right so it's not like maybe frightening
for kids but it's just Sinister enough
to kind of give him that taste like yeah
I agree oh man some really dark elements
in it oh yeah I mean even Insanity
imprisonment
poverty I mean you know it's funny when
you look back on these movies it's
interesting like how valuable
um Frozen is to like synopsis of Disney
characters which is basically that
Jasmine has to get married when she's 16
to someone she doesn't know she's
meeting all these suitors and everyone's
like giving her all this [__] everyone's
like oh you're so picky Jasmine why
can't you just find a husband in a day
and like they give her so much crap
throughout the movie for being like this
pain in the wiener and she's like that
is a difficult oh dang it secret it's
Jasmine and it's like it's so unfair
the whole thing like she's treated like
garbage and she she chooses Aladdin
based on a ride
like basically basically she gets one
ride on his
well but no to be fair he also rescues
her you know a little bit from like the
guy who's gonna cut her hand off secret
her hand is literally like a second away
from being chopped off Aladdin caught
the guy's hand mid-strike yeah I guess
that's true that was sort of the start
of the whole thing but is that the kind
of thing though like when that happens
like you owe them your life or whatever
what no but that no but that that
started everything
suppose she this like she trusted him
immediately because she was like oh it's
just my crazy sister and then she
started she called what she called like
a camel no like an elephant or something
like oh are you the are you the Shah
I don't know anyway yeah I mean yeah
yeah they had some they had like some
secret moments but I'm just saying she
doesn't know him at all and she like
she has to marry some dude that she
doesn't really know
it's the character that counts
well everyone she deals with on a daily
basis is sort of like you know oh
whatever you know but he's he does
things that are good for their people he
looks out for her
they do have some chemistry
Arab
that ends that level for some reason
that's like one of the few levels where
like obtaining something ends the level
as opposed to like going into a area
where the level's over all right
so much is writing on this
damn it
well done Street rats
that's not what he says in the movie and
it didn't happen in this order at all
they had to like just like Lion King
they had to like skip so much and retcon
events as well yeah
because Jafar already had the two pieces
of the scare of at this point he did he
did he didn't need the Scarab he wanted
oh you hit me with a stick
my only weakness
all right so if I
kill this snake I think there's a secret
over here
but that snake is
there we go so in this level for no
reason I'm trying to get these flutes
also you'll notice that this is the
first song in the movie is now in the
third level of the game yes
scoundrel take that just a little snack
such a good song
um this is where they start employing
ropes to get through the level it
doesn't make any sense not in the movie
it is not in any other part
pots
that guy steals your apples he would
I'm just gonna hit you with apples
um the ropes always come back so you can
use them to get a lot of Secrets and
stuff like that that are hidden
throughout this level
these guys don't appreciate that I'm a
pro
so you were mentioning you need apples
to kill bosses like how many apples per
boss because I was trying to be
conservative with my apple right I mean
they will give you apples to finish a
boss they never they never put you in a
death State like you'll never you'll
never not have enough apples so the um
there's two major bosses that require
apples there's Iago who is running in a
machine
um there's like this really awesome
scene in the movie yeah where you have
to like
it sort of operates jafar's like
underground laboratory that's exactly
right well okay you have to stop Iago in
that machine gotcha uh and you do it by
throwing apples at him and then there's
another uh the final boss Jafar and this
is such a silly boss as you
you have to like throw apples at the
snake and uh it's really tough I think
honest to God it might be the hardest
boss
I mean it's definitely harder than any
boss it's harder than um the bosses in
the secret it's harder than any boss
like in The Lion King that's for damn
sure it takes so long for me to beat it
um and it's really tedious too because
you basically spend the whole time
trying to not get hit by fire
um the way that the fireworks again is
just like the Kohl's is it doesn't hit
you as long as you're moving so you have
to constantly run without ever stopping
and throw apples at him sounds legit you
basically go run back and forth and it
takes oh son of a beer I have to go so
far back now
sorry guys
um it's a huge pain and I think it's a
really tedious crappy boss but that's
the way they decided to do it so
I don't make the rules Gotta Eat to Live
gotta live to eat tell you about it when
I got the time
so you were telling me a story uh about
you and your sister in Aladdin
I have many stories about me and my
sister well the one in particular where
you would reenact it oh yeah yeah this
is kind of embarrassing no I think it's
great
um me and my sisters really liked this
movie and like maybe one of those creepy
ways like where we watched this a lot in
our childhood it was like just something
we watched all the time we knew it so
well
that
was weird
um
what we'd do was uh we would take these
cabins when we were kids and
um in the cabin we didn't really have
anything to do we had these voice
recorders which was
you know just like recorded your voice
when you were a kid and we would reenact
the entire movie from beginning to end
with me and my two sisters and because I
was the youngest they gave me the shitty
role so I was
um I was the lamp
uh or sorry yeah I was like uh carpet
which as you might be familiar with
doesn't have any lines uh I believe I
was Iago they let me be Iago Gilbert
Godfrey
they were pretty they were pretty cruel
both of my sisters got to be all the
good roles they got to be Jasmine
Aladdin the um Genie and Jafar were you
ever Raja the tiger I was Raja so I was
basically anyone anything you can
imagine it if it was yeah
if it was a non-speaking character or an
animal that was me I was a boo
um that was what I got that's complex
that's not easy but that's what we did
as kids we like literally reenacted this
movie I don't think I know it as well as
when I did when I was a kid but I
genuinely knew that movie so good I knew
it from beginning to end which one of
you was the the lady who like pops out
like during this song in the movie
oh yeah
yeah
she gets real throaty with it though
well she she might have a problem she's
a little weirdo remember which one you
played her oh man I'm gonna die
um
I think I did I think I was if it was a
crappy role it was me basically if
that's your question
I don't think she's crappy at all she's
a vital character she certainly is get
away from me I'll go
okay
all right there is a boss over here
which is a weird thing and he's kind of
hard and I don't have a lot of freaking
life but if you beat him
he's a safe state if you beat him you
get all these extra bonuses that you
don't get so it's worth doing so if I
can't beat him you can
oh this guy
this is the guy who gets sent into the
Cave of Wonders at first that's correct
but he's not the diamond in the rough
so to speak
I'm gonna die
great work
that gave me a lot more life and then
he takes me through health and all these
um apples so it's like a bonus if you
can beat him yeah
now I get full health and all these
scrumptious apples now your apples max
out at 99 so as you can see I have 97 I
might as well just start throwing them
this is another boss where you require
apples to beat them
um basically you freaking throw apples
at the guy
and he throws barrels at you this is so
similar to Lion King it's ridiculous
it's basically the monkey remember the
monkey boss I remember you guys remember
the monkey bars
it's the same freaking thing
it's got to be at the height of your
well the so the timing with these games
is so shitty that you have to yes has to
be at the top but that means you have to
press the button before you get to this
that's correct that is so correct I got
you eat apple that's the only thing I
don't like about this in Lion King it's
just so floaty
so loose it is
it is a pain
I think it's it's funny like
as a kid you probably get really
adjusted to the controls too like I got
really adjusted to
to like jumping earlier than necessary
so much that now maybe when I have a
game I probably like don't jump I jump
earlier than necessary because I like
I'm so adjusted to it come on
one two three four damn
so I get that strategy I think it was my
strategy when I was a kid but I don't
think it ever worked I think it was one
two three maybe one two three hit I
can't remember trust me you guys I have
a strategy oh look it's Jasmine
oh you were wrong well she's not
playable in the game at all
well the game's not called Jasmine
I wish it was
basically the whole game you just have
to choose a husband
this is actually a really difficult
level
um it has a lot of Hearts because it's
so difficult to beat and check it out
bats not only are bats back but I'm
pretty sure it's the same damn animation
and look and everything that poor dog
like they didn't even change it it's the
same bat I'm confident it's the same
stupid time
foreign
Jungle Book
yeah I think we have the Jungle Book as
well these were like the ones that I
played the crap out of I'd say most
people played you know Latin or Lion
King you don't hear a lot about the
Jungle Book game no I don't think it was
as
popular
um a lot of people probably remember
these guys from the movie just kidding
they are not in the movie and they're so
annoying
um if he changes his head and you don't
stop him with a bomb he explodes in all
of his bones can hurt you so it's kind
of vital that you that you knock him out
before he does that or he's a pain in
the wiener to deal with
he really is no I totally I can't
emphasize enough what a pain in the
wiener he is
they're the foremost expert on wiener
pain at GameSpot
oh no
those bones bones you got boned I got
so boned
have a car a carpets and fly to another
ride
bone guy I'm gonna see what's going on
in the chat yeah how are you guys doing
do you guys have any questions
shoot me some questions any questions
questions about I practiced this last
night so I feel confident that I could
answer most of the questions regarding
Aladdin game guard your wiener Mary oh
my God my wiener
ooh shop
I'll have a I'll buy a life it's a deal
now obviously save uh continues are
worth more because they're worth three
lives but
I don't know I'm not really planning on
using any of those anyway because
because you're just so good
uh well because we have saved States so
I can cheat so it's not really as
well but if you guys were playing this
without that I would recommend
that you did by the continues and not
the saves for the lives because they
don't have as much value
these blocks are notoriously annoying
because if you fall you have to go all
the way back down and sometimes you
really should land and they don't let
you how annoying is that
you know I'm just gonna throw apples at
you
idiot stupid idiot idiot a guy thinks
I'm gonna fight him hey you guys see
this idiot I'm a thief I'm not going to
fight fair I'm going to throw apples at
you oh no he's too far
like imagine if Aladdin wasn't
attractive right and he had like a
really bad voice go on I don't think
that he would be as revered by the
public because everyone just seems to be
infatuated with him except for maybe the
occasional Apple vendor you know and the
palace his Antics are cheeky and fun
they're not annoying but women love him
predominantly it's like the women that
sort of defend him right yeah
whatever happened to the the thieves
that aren't so attractive
well they don't get movies made about
them I suppose see double standard no
just a standard
just a standard it's a regular standard
yeah I suppose you're right I mean
Aladdin was
was a hottie with a body I mean they did
refer to his stench a few times so I
imagine he smelled awful remember that
oh yeah oh yeah in the movie they
referred to him smelling bad yeah
I remember that you bats
freaking hate bats
all right I'm almost about to die but
there is a heart over here if I can get
to it
Hearts only replenish two of your hit
points so it's like not
it's not worth it if you get hit getting
there and getting back basically
secret little secret apples I already
have 99 has no value
but that's not the point the point is it
was a secret
that's what really matters you see that
um it looks like a Mac on button
I wonder what I think they're just
chains they're just shackles well the
yeah where you would attach a chain
where you would attach you know I don't
see enough uh decrepit dead people in
this you'd think if this was a dungeon
there would be a lot of like death the
dungeon was a lot smaller in the movie
too and Aladdin was only in it for maybe
three minutes before old man Jafar was
basically like not everything is as it
seems and he like pops a little thing on
the wall yeah they really don't show how
like you know he probably had jaundice
and
well he was only in there for like a day
I don't think he developed jaundice
every day die
maybe you do maybe there's accelerated
jaundice in the desert
all right Apple
tweeted apples apples Peter glorious
fruit
oh the fruit
all right
you know I'm just gonna I'm just I'm not
gonna I don't give a [__] about you
and they'll give anyone a turban and a
sword
their standards are so low money money
money money
um there's a spike to the left here so
there's kind of like a little a little
bit of a timing thing going on here I
think it's
go okay
the timing is really sensitive here
those guys are so easy
I can't believe they just put names
I didn't really think this through this
dungeon
and Anna
so yeah the Jungle Book game was made by
virgin as well
I kind of want to play a little here
yeah you do it your hands are bored you
do it
I'll tell you more important oh and then
I have to do the escape from the lava
thing uh that's after this right
eventually yes
this is a really
um I would save it this is a really hard
level
I don't think
um apples work on bats
they're so unpredictable
cheers
um so you need to those guys that have
the thing instead of grabbing it like
you do in the movie you hit it with your
sword for some reason
there's a lot of hearts in this level
which is good to I think Make Up For
What a what like how difficult it is
they throw stuff at you you want to hit
them with your sword as well I did but
she didn't do anything you just got to
do it again
so many bats
so what do I have to
um go back and hit that lady
just go back and forth
no no like throw um swing while you go
back and forth there you go
it's kind of annoying it's very specific
I know and then
you want to jump in the center of that
to make it rise
I think there's a secret
I can't remember jump
I love that do it again
thank you
can you do that the bats I swear to God
those bats are such a pain
yeah
eat a DB that'll fall jump you gotta
jump there you go good job yay
spikes for you Peter
um yeah there's another heart
there's so many hearts because there's
so many bats I think in testing they
realize that everyone was freaking dying
and that children would never be able to
play the game so am I going to the left
here yeah you kind of jumped to your
left I think oh if I could have jumped
if only
laughs
it's okay kid we've got this
you gotta see that you can do this
uh the spikes again for you Peter
double Spike two oh man are you sure you
go to left there I guess I don't have
any other choice yes I'm pretty sure
okay okay yeah
they'll continue throwing things at you
until you hit them
I have no plan on
all right this part's pretty difficult
um what am I actually dealing with okay
so there's just rocks constantly falling
and if you stand they seem to stop so
you see how they always go over a
certain area that's where you want to
stand and then you jump on that um you
can go for the monkey if you want
there's also ghosts for some reason
um they have uh
what is that called like they have no
texture it's like it's like lines it's
just a bunch of Stripes it's very weird
well they couldn't do transparency so
like if you jump up and to the right you
will grab those
while you're supposed to
uh yeah jump to the right oh you did it
oh my hearts get that heart you need it
there was a bat behind him bats
you're getting wamped
he wouldn't do his attack back and forth
oh this game
there's a heart if you jump to your left
so but there's also a bag all right
there's bats everywhere that's
everywhere
thank you oh get that yeah checkpoint
what does he say in the movie when you
take
you touched the Forbidden treasure oh
yeah and everything starts you will
never see the light of day
it's a really powerful scene actually it
moved me to tears they
oh [__] oh this could be it this could
be it for you Peter stop it no
confidence Mary
you can do it Peter
I think the bats are what don't help
foreign
two hits
yeah do those bats
no mercy bats are pain they're just
all right we're throwing gems at me
she'll probably hit me no matter what I
do
okay we got people saying the SNES
version of this game is better I want to
hear your arguments yeah let's do it
explain yourselves also DJ Carr says
this game is so easy I don't know how
you guys keep dying LOL
that guy sounds like a huge wiener
that's my response if I'm allowed to
retort
um
this game has its points where I think
it's easy but I mean like I I have beat
it I beat it yesterday so I feel
confident that I can beat it again
whatever your name is
um the NES version has better graphics
I'm not sure I agree
you would know that
the animations are definitely Superior
here and the colors look great like
would you want anything more out of a
16-bit game I can't ask for anything
more than what this game has given me
oh shoot it's another boss
um
this guy's annoying
um he spits apples at you and he goes
back and forth
um you know you hit him when he poops
into smoke
[__]
I can't remember exactly how to get him
I just think you
there you go I got him there
he'll be proactive yeah I think you just
[__] swing at him
idiot
you're dead you're dead monkey man
he's not in the movie I've never seen
this guy before he's very weird looking
he's got this big Buddha belly and he's
I don't know where they got the idea for
this boss
all right I got him
wow
all right
he'll eventually leave me save State all
right this one's really annoying and
there's fish
so the fish
spit at you
do you want to give it a whirl let's do
it so you jump before you need to jump
before you need to
I would save it do a Save State
oh no I think you're dead now don't save
it don't no it'll come back is it
literally it's going to leave me
stranded I think you're dead I actually
think you're dead can I Blame You
sure
I'm just gonna stand here for a while my
Apple no I want to beat the game
do a safe State when you're back
you wanted you want to land on that
middle one so bad yeah let me get one
more shot yeah sure sure
[__] this
oh that goddamn timing load state
all right
the timing is weird here
fish
I don't understand that
oh
rocks
all right I got it so I think this is
the famous the Escape ride sequence I am
gonna save it as soon as I get there
because
oh
darn you Jafar I hate you
you're only giving him more power one
two three
one uh I said I only had two you earned
those throughout the level I think you
get things
do it infidels
you touch the forbid
you've touched the Forbidden treasure
yeah I feel like I'm there I'll be a boo
he's like a really squeaky scratchy kind
of a monkey call though he was cute oh
this okay
I would I would reckon this is the
hardest
the hardest level you're on the wrong
things sweetheart safe yeah I almost
died
waste it
thanks sweet hat
all right again Boulders are back
remember Boulders in the movie nope me
neither
if it touches your foot you die
even if you're totally clear of it if it
touches your ankle you freaking die it's
stupid
ah
go on
oh I knew that was gonna happen
all right this seems like you're gonna
die but if you jump to the right you
grab that thingy
I died
I think you do die
so you grab the is it a slight tight or
still like my which one comes out of the
the top oh that's
science I stag might
sounds like a really confident answer
not at all like a yes
huh
sorry do you mind if I give it one more
shot no no I feel like I got this do it
yeah
oh
garbage
I'm confident that that's what you do no
I believe you I'll just give you [__]
um I don't know why
I'll just save it again because I
thought that that's what you do
maybe you don't I'm just gonna jump
forward
I don't know what I'm doing
I don't know anything about the world
all right I think there's three Boulders
in a row for whatever reason that's what
they decided to do
oh [__] you're only allowed to jump once
or the boulder will get you but you can
go back
to obtain these precious gems
I touched my ankle
it can't touch super unfair your ankle
all right I got this
apple apple Jim
and this one it's like the second one is
a gem I think
so yeah did the gems determine how many
things you get in the bonus round no
no so why are you are you why are you
really dedicated to getting them
um you can buy things with them and they
increase your score so it's actually you
were talking you were saying who needs a
score earlier well now I feel like this
whole thing is just inconsistent well
I'm inconsistent not the game no yes I'm
saying you this whole thing you're
calling me this whole thing yeah this
entire friendship is just it's I don't
even know what to believe I feel like
I'm under a lot of pressure
foreign
yeah
I'm Aladdin yeah
oh I'm the [__] did it
suck it who was that guy you said I
wasn't good at the game
uh
uh what eat it he said I wasn't good at
the game oh
somebody flat out and said damn Peter
sucks LOL which is true I'm not good at
Disney games yeah but like
this takes a long time to like look at
this did you notice if I didn't have a
save state that I would have started at
the beginning of the level no
checkpoints not a one
it's a very stupid game
and when I mean stupid I mean awesome
there are a bunch of people calling it
super easy I just like it's really the
hang up with the the controls for me
um
I think it can give you grief for sure
last night when I was practicing I was
doing better
but
I'm still confident
you can go back here and get all sorts
of delicious bonuses but I don't think
it's completely necessary
for us to do that
I think this is another freaking Boulder
oh my God
it's gonna get my ankle it rolls uphill
just as fast as it rolls downhill
all right so now I believe is the carpet
ride it better be
I hate you Jafar
maybe that's the secret
one two three
that's the secret
stupid Jafar
so much energy I hate that it's good
it's really irritating to have five
things oh look at these bread loaves I
think they're gold but it totally looks
like bread me and my sisters used to
always say like we were just collecting
bread
because that is what he's stealing at
the beginning of the game
yeah
right on
um now there's a secret here
it's right go yeah
yeah those are about the only ones I
know on this level actually I'm gonna do
this right now before I forget okay
all right because they get a lot faster
um I think the secret personally to this
level is that you stay on the bottom
unless it tells you not to be on the
bottom it protects you pretty much the
entire level if you just stay on the
freaking bottom unless he points up you
just freaking see so you're only
avoiding those rocks that appear and the
top of that lava wave
that's only the rocks
um
only the Rocks but it gets really fast
um towards the end but there's not a
point when the weight yeah
if you stay on the bottom that's
animation to like just make it clear
what's happening but if you just stay on
thank you for that if you just stay on
the bottom are safe honest to God
it's not real lava Peter don't worry all
right just so you know you're safe with
me Peter this is just a video game it's
not real life I don't know if you were
worried
oh I'm scared one of these isn't up
it's coming up
I did it
what should you do scary I like that
question mark at the end it's just like
you made it this far you're about to
beat it we're not gonna We're not gonna
tell you what's going on um I think the
next level is the infamous uh Genie
level
I don't know the genie level
oh you bastard
she's far
he's so
he's such so yeah this is inside the
lamb this is a sweet sweet level this is
like everyone's favorite level
and it's got the song
and it's got all sorts of hidden
Secrets this reminds me of like an
earthworm gem level it's so creative
it's really fun it's filled with like
womp noises and um check this out when
you touch his beard
like it's just funny how long did you do
that for last night all the time
so you can actually beat the game you
just spent all night doing that I forgot
about that uh yeah when I mean beat the
game I mean you got to this point I
had a lot of fun
you can like
Secrets everywhere in this level this
may be my least favorite song in the
whole movie oh really yeah
Secret
it's just all about random things that
rhyme with the previous are you not a
fan of the actor who plays him no
actually I like Robin Williams but I
feel like for the for this song in
particular like they're like all right
we need you to be Robin Williams but you
know like as much as you can like
there's just I don't know it's just like
there's no point to a lot of stuff he's
saying
I don't know if you guys ever played
this game and you were like
what am I supposed to do here I actually
got stuck for a really long time here
because it takes a while for these hands
to be triggered and actually show up and
until they do you basically just think
that the game is broken it's kind of
dumb but then but then they show up and
everything's okay it's with the letters
uh I think they're in the movie
I'm not entirely sure it's purpose oh
yeah this is when
this is okay again so similar to Lion
King like remember the part where I'm
just like jumping from Stone to Stone
yeah and this one it's the same like
really light-hearted touch but I'm doing
it with the balloons
um when you touch the balloon you
basically have a second or two before he
explodes
for whatever reason
Secret
it's a deal what are you buying
hand
um the only thing that kind of sucks
about that secret is now I have to do
this whole sequence again I have to do
the balloons but because I'm really good
at it it's not a huge problem
do with my eyes closed
I can't
I'm scared
am I doing it you got one you got one
patience is a virtue on this level if
you try to rush it you're way more
likely to die
there's a secret there's so much secret
in the goo it's weird that you like
constantly just get stuck in a skew
though I'm gonna find that a little
gross
but I guess that's that's the way they
wanted it
up a little hands is the part with the
hookers can your friends go
lookie here can your friends go
Abracadabra they set him up with he sets
them up with like four prostitutes as
you put it sure does and they are
grinding up on Aladdin so hard oh
they're all up in his apples
I noticed that last night I was like wow
all right this part's stupid
so the way you do this is um the timing
is you jump on the bottom hand the top
hand then you re-jump on the top hand
when it disappears and then jump back on
the top hand it takes me sometimes a few
tries
it really sucks
here we go I did it
oh that was
I know that makes me look like it was
really easy but it's actually kind of
hard
especially when you're a kid man like I
think a lot of these things they're not
that hard but when you're just a kid
like oh yeah oh challenging yeah
like I found that stuff to be like
really challenging as a tot
as a wee one flick
all right
there's like a mini hand coming up it's
so weird
just land on this tiny mutant hand and
it's so hard to run and jump off of it
all right cool that's it that's that one
good job yeah
so we're getting pretty close to the end
of the game actually we're getting
pretty close to the end of the stream
too oh no what time is it 11 55
one two three yeah
I really wanted to beat this
um let's get the story
um
I think I mean there's so much this is
the end
honest to God I think this is the last
level
I know that sounds crazy but I really do
think it's the last
I'm gonna be honest with you that sounds
crazy
well
believe it or not sounds like the words
of a crazy person I beat it yesterday
and I'm pretty sure that this is the
last level because it's the Sultan's
Palace
yeah this game just like I hate that
gloss is making fish
die
stupid fish
um
the carpet will always come back
if you want him to
um so there's all these secrets like
you'll notice there's Secrets all over
this stupid map you gotta jump off the
carpet at the correct time and then get
back to where you were and redo where
the carpet took you so it's kind of not
worth it it's worth it if you don't
cheat like I have saved States I don't
really need all that stuff but it's
totally worth it if you need that stuff
kind of hard to say explain eat apple
stupid
I didn't think that guy was there
I'm gonna die oh wow
I really do think I can I this is the
level I really do
if I could convince you no I'm willing
to believe you
it doesn't look like the final state
does it because it's like kind of
friendly looking but I'm pretty sure
this is the final level
because remember like in um
um in Lion King the final level seems
final like it's all aggressive and stuff
but this one it's like happy until you
get to Jafar
oh he got me twice that was really bad
so I think if you'd walked into that
lamp wouldn't have killed every guy on
screen it kills that guy but I looked
down when I did it and it only kills
them if they're right they're visible
yeah so I kind of I
you're saying you screwed up you're
admitting
um
I'll give it a shot yeah we'll see what
happens I really want to beat the game I
can as long as you guys are willing to
wait it out with me do you want to save
it or no you don't have to sure why not
um so you will have to get on the this
is a really good battle that you have
going on you have to get on that carpet
and stay on them I think the best way to
not get hit on the carpet is to
um hit up and use your sword is so if
you just hold up and use your sword you
kind of go back and forth to your left
and to your right and protects both
sides of you I think you have a better
chance than if you look a particular
direction and swing
and where do I get off you stay stay on
it it'll drop you
um this is another one of those things
where I didn't realize now hit that guy
to the right yeah
uh you would me and my sisters would
always jump off of it because that seems
like that's what you should do right
like but that's not what you're supposed
to do it makes the game a lot harder
I didn't realize like I was throwing
knives now
foreign
ER my undies I think that's a reference
to
um up and up and when
when you first meet Jasmine and she has
a Suitor
yeah and the guy walks out with his
underwear showing yeah so but his under
like his butt isn't exposed but like so
you think oh he just ripped his pants
like the Tiger but the Jasmine's tiger
has his underwear in his mouth that's
right that's right it's kind of a weird
I think it's supposed to be like funny
you think it's funny it's gonna drop you
off
get some butt that's all I'm saying so
if you fall you have to redo that
sequence which am I going left or right
I can't remember probably to the right
right
oh nope if you get those which you
totally can you have to redo this
evening I'm not doing it okay but should
I jump on the platform to the right no
that's not a platform oh it's that
little wall on the way
nice
I'm excited oh it was just it was
unlucky that you landed on him
that could have happened to anyone
we're gonna beat it we're gonna beat it
right now this is it
this is when we beat the game damn it
and you still get hit when you do this
um I have a better technique which is
called spamming left and right
um which actually works better I know
that sounds weird but it does
oh
he hit me twice
that guy hit me too
that's it I'm pure apple from here on
out
um what really sucks too is about this
end State
um if you kill Jafar
um in your first life you have like a
hundred apples right but if you die then
you have 10 apples and you have to beat
Jafar with 10 apples every time and it
sucks it absolutely sucks you were
saying before that the game gives you
more apples like it's 10 it does it
feels like there's no room then you have
to go get them so it only gives you
apples when you run out of apples so it
sounds kind of sounds like I'm just
complaining to complain but the thing is
is so that means that I ca I have to
once I'm out of apples then I have to go
retrieve apples before I can fight Jafar
again let me ask you this is this carpet
drunk or something because it's just
like I don't know
it basically just takes you on the
craziest route when it just needs to go
straight up I know it's soft game
I just want to get to the next safe save
you Yago
um
I just want to get to the next save
because I'll save the game
there's a bunch of Hearts coming up
and when I get there
um
so no I don't want to do it yet that's
what did I do
I'm just gonna throw apples like it's my
job
everyone suck it oh I can free a boo
here this is pretty cute
oh
rendezvous
be free be a free monkey
um I could buy stuff I wish I could buy
some freaking apples is what I want to
buy
I don't really need anything
oh for butt sakes
you see what just happened to me Peter
good yeah you got spite
oh
all right
job
oh this isn't the final level you guys
aren't gonna let me play anymore
I was wrong
all right so if I stay here
oh I'm out of apples
see this yep do you see why not having
apples is a pain
cheese
you just gotta pick a side and go with
it no I keep going back and forth
they're going to keep appearing where
you are well they appear anyway well I
know but they appear where you are
that's the that's the difference
oh I'm out of apples
I hate you ghosts
um you know you're getting
close when he starts wrapping around it
like like he just did
he just disappeared that ghost like
lucky
also kind of done that you can't just
hit him with your sword considering you
know that he's a bird and I could
totally kill him
in fact I've seen you kill him no fewer
than a dozen times I know he's like just
a regular player and then all of a
sudden he's
actual problem
okay good he's dead he did it good job I
beat the game I'm just kidding uh we're
gonna have to call it after this though
after my next death
sure this is the final level I'm serious
don't you guys want to watch me beat the
game I don't have time I do
so important that we beat this
don't you guys nobody wants to beat us
I'm gonna hurry up
I'm gonna hurry up and you guys are
gonna be so excited that we beat the
game
you're gonna be so proud of me
I might be and then and then as a treat
you're gonna buy me lunch sure and the
song at the end of the when you beat the
game is I will show you the world
so I mean come on like yeah but it is
going to take 30 minutes and you're
still not beating it like that you can't
do that no I'm totally not gonna do that
this time
I know that that's what happened last
time but I have a really good feeling
about this one
and I practiced a lot last night
I did I know how to beat Jafar
yeah
come on
oh you [__]
see look how good I am
feel like you're not taking into account
how good I am
pretty sure you've you've established
all these fears but have you taken into
consideration
how good I am
so there is a secret if I jump off there
but I'm not going to because I need to
hurry up and beat this game before you
make me quiz
so many bad guys at once here
this is how you know you're at the end
these spikes I know they make it like
just wide enough I know all right I'm
really close this is pretty much the
home stretch before I get to the final
bad dude
oh that was not worth it
all right there's two hearts up here
which is why I did that but if you get
hit a few times it's not worth it let's
do it again
all right
there's also a secret up here
not worth it
it's not worth it it's not worth it I'm
gonna beat the game I'm gonna do it
all right this is it this is the final
stretch so as you'll notice I'm spamming
left and right and hitting uh attack
that's the best way to not get hit right
before you attack Jafar honest to God
I'll I will like personally vouch for
that
all right so this is the final boss it's
really freaking hard it might take me
another save it so you don't have to do
any of this over again sure it's
probably a good idea
it might take me
like a few tries give you five tries all
right Peter
far is
is really tough um he what he's doing is
he's sucking me in with his little staff
of lame
um I have to hit him with apples
um but if he when he hits me with his
staff I have to get away from him
immediately
um and he will suck me in eventually
when he does that I gotta jump over his
head to get away
and even then he can hit me but you
notice I'm hitting him with apples when
I can this isn't even his final form he
turns into a snake soon
I really want to show you his snake form
and then that's when it actually gets
tough all right now he's a snake you
don't have any apples left I know so now
they appear when I run out
oh I'm gonna freaking die
might as well save it no what it's too
hard
oh
I'm gonna die
all right it's okay it's okay it's okay
I get another try Peter said I did don't
worry guys
I got it I got this
I was the hole up in his grill did you
see that he sucks me in with his oh
fudge you got me twice
the less he gets me the more I have life
to deal with the final snake which is
way more difficult so I'd rather not be
get hit by him at all if possible but
it's really hard because you were doing
really good before when you stood in
that one spot and just kept getting in
oh I can hear him I can hear him just
don't run away after you you hear him
get hit yeah well he'll he'll eventually
pull me in with his Stars well I'm just
saying last time you got like six hits
on him
support I need your support you can do
this
oh he got me again
hey Jafar
all right he's a snake but I'm almost
dead so this is really bad
I'm doing really bad sorry guys
how many more do I get yeah three more
tries all right but seriously that's
what I was saying the first time you
fought him yeah you were at a point
where you had him stuck in a loop where
you would hit him with an apple and he
wouldn't be able to do a star thing but
last time you were running backwards
instead of holding your ground
is he always gummy and his Stars
so you gotta switch when he has you that
close you have to
I hate you
see I did it that time you gotta like
jump over his head when he does that
get away from me
creeper
oh no I didn't even get all my apples I
gotta get more apples
jumped over you stupid
you got me anyway
jeez he's whopping me all over
no hey Jafar all right we need to read
we need to think about this
I'm I'm in like the same really bad
state
all right he's a snake
let's do this
all right so the trick is to jump over
the fire and to hit him with an apple at
the same time
when you run out of apples you gotta
jump
you have to hit him oh [__] ton of times
if the snake hits you you die you don't
get any extra points
too far
that doesn't count
you guys are in the back remember this
remember this last week remember we did
this last week you guys aren't hungry
I have so much work to do
but you got this I do think that you can
do this
come on you guys
support just don't do that anymore
oh I'm out of apples
turn into a snake you demon
yes oh save your game save your game all
right
all right
all right I'm out of apples
you gotta jump over him there like which
I didn't do last time
I got it I got it I'm in the zone
I'm not
fun
you have to hit him so many times
die
foreign
oh no
I still had an apple left
got him
good job
that's how you beat Aladdin
all right here we go here we go we can
do this Peter
I can show you though
tell me Peter when was the last time I
won this game
I can open your eyes
Peter you have to join me
I can't do it no it's all you own it no
one to tell us
that's all I can't do this
oh you're so good you should do it you
can actually do this
indescribable
feelings
tumbling and freewheeling through an
endless Diamond sky
don't you dare close your eyes
damn thousand things to see hold your
breath it gets better
I can't go back to where I used to be
oh man all right well everyone while
Mary's singing we're gonna sign off
thanks for watching Mega bit we'll be
back next week with another great old
game
maybe Mary will be back we'll see down
the road
um come back today at 2 p.m for multiple
players with uh Chris Waters he's back
in town
marry everybody
place for you and
all right take care folks